يتكرر السيناريو في المسجد الاقصى وتقضي
محاولات التقسيم الزمني له بتخصيص اوقات
لليهود لزياره صباحا وبعد الظهيره وتحضر
عليهم الصلاه من قبل السلطات الاحتلال
ويتضاعف عدد الذين يدخلون المسجد الاقصى
خلال الاعياد اليهوديه ولا يتم منع
المسلمين من الصلاه
يرجح تقرير لمؤسسه القدس الدوليه ان
الاحتلال يمهد لفرض تقسيم المكان للاقصى
عبر الاستيلاء على منطقتين الاولى في
الجهه الغربيه امام باب المغاربه قرب حائط
البراق الذي يقيم عنده اليهود طقوسهم
التلموديه ويسمونه حائط المبكى والمنطقه
الثانيه تقع في الجهه الشرقيه لمقبره باب
الرحمه التي صدر الاحتلال جزءا منها وهي
المنطقه التي يؤدي اليهود عندها بعض
الطقوس قباله قبه الصخره ولتر تاريخ هذا
الامر الواقع فرض الاحتلال قيودا شملت
ابعاد مصلينا باوامر من الشرطه وحضر ما
سماه تنظيم المرابطين والمرابطات وحلقات
العلم في المسجد الاقصى